just don't let me catch you in season
two i know you better not [ __ ] him
you better not hurt him
[Applause]
well this isn't your first video game we
cannot forget about journey to the
center of hawkthorn from community
oh my gosh you put that together oh
you're
too much in our little pac-man s
community
version oh yeah that's so sharp of you i
completely missed that
no it's not my first go-round then i'm a
pro
i'm certainly a pro after playing uh
anton castillo in far cry 6. he's
certainly changed the game and
the technology used and the the way it's
done
really taught me a new skill yeah
slightly improved likeness
i would say yeah i know i hated my
community did you blackhead person
didn't look anything like me
now i'll have that crystal there is a
lot of a lot of hype and speculation
going on about you
possibly being in far cry 6. i play um
el presidente
anton castillo who is the dictator of a
very small caribbean island
trying to remain autonomous from other
countries
who would like to take and probably um
exploit their natural resources
anton is a father of a son who he's
grooming to take over for him
after whatever happens with his
success or failure and trying to put
down a revolutionary force who wants to
take over his country
so you meet anton at a very stressful
place in his existence
um trying to empower his people to still
trust him
and trusted his vision uh to return
yada uh to its former
uh glory what was it like when you saw
the kind of final for the first time
i you know i i argued that that they
were
fooling me that's really how i felt i i
looked at it at night
it was so very realistic almost super
real
and i couldn't really i couldn't
determine whatsoever
that that they built me and i really
i told my my representation i said
that's that's not it's no they didn't
build me that's me
so i'm quite amazed at what they can do
have you gotten to play at all
i played a little bit while i was there
in between shooting i'm so bad
but they started to show me how it works
and they promised me that when i go back
up to be with them again
because i want to play this this game
and learn how to put
to really be a gamer through this game
one that i've had the honor to appear in
i think
it's also i think technologically i'll
just say
you know games take a long time to
develop so
expect that there are new and wonderful
visual ideas that are brought to this
game that i think will be
very very the aesthetic will be very
pleasing to the audience
so you did motion capture for this what
would you say the biggest challenge was
for you being in that role i had to
always remind myself
that even though i don't have this
button to touch
or unbutton because the motion capture
suit doesn't have that
that that button is still there that
that belt is still
on that my physicality is still royal
and regal
that that i go through time as anton
experiencing physically what he will
experience in the piece which allows our
viewer our player to experience it
so that's a different feeling and that's
a different allowance of someone else
into your journey um again
on a multi-layered level so physicality
um the idea of placing things
in the room that aren't there um
and allowing those things to have an
effect on you
that was probably a very large challenge
as well right it's like
improv or like you said theater where
you're like yup here's the phone like
that's exactly it and so all day
in shooting with such great support from
these this great team
uh you know in toronto
i would remind myself that if
you believe it they will believe it you
know
if you believe it they'll believe it
it's like the exact opposite of
mandalorian where they have like the
real screens
and you're like really seeing everything
that's there
that's right that's the different world
the wide open world which allows me to
have a costume
which puts me in a room where they can
put everything because every all the
screens are the whole room so you make
whatever you want and the physical
vehicle that i might be traveling on
might be plopping into the room and i
gotta imagine everything but at least i
got a costume
i'm pretty badass right in the other
situation i've gotta think like the
mandalorian i gotta think
like moff gideon as anton
i've got to bring all that thinking
without having
the realization of a breastplate or a
cape
or anything else so different styles
but certainly the same amount of
commitment right you know
and and i would say adventure to say
even more commitment
in the the world in which we shoot our
motion capture well i gotta ask you
about mandalorian because i did
a lot of those panels and i didn't
really get to talk to you because your
character was so under wraps
uh but now we know kind of what his deal
is so
i have to know your reaction when you
found out you were going to be wielding
the dark saber and what it looks like on
set because it was one of the most
badass shots i've ever seen
i i have to say it's um such an honor
you know very few have wielded that
saber
it just was really wonderful to be in
the organic
version of this story um
john favreau asked me to do it i was
head over heels he mentioned that he had
written it for me
i went and started to look at old mops
what's a moth
you know i went back and looked at peter
cushing was a moth you know
what do they do who are they uh and then
was really present in conversations with
john about
his imperial status his carry over from
the empire
um how moss operated why
possibly leaving room it's always
possibly
why he might be um the moth to take
everything over
how does he know everything there were a
bunch of questions and so
which some of them got answered and many
of them not because he's still trying to
find that out
so to be in the position of having that
kind of regal
graceful power but have this saver which
delineates a different part of me
than any other character um
to have this saber means i'm i'm i can
use it
and i can do my own dirty work that i'm
a fighter that i'm a warrior that's part
of me
also creates the possibility of
that he um is
uh you know one of the ones
you know like he possibly has
that and that to me
is interesting because is he really that
fallen hero
is he you know uh is he
a descendant of darth vader who is he
what does he want
he knows all about everything and you'll
have to wait to find out
yeah he's actually pretty good with that
dark saber too okay
there's a lot of setup for season two
i'm very excited about um
my other question for you regarding that
is when you found out that
like his whole drive in the first season
was just to go after this adorable
little baby yoda like what did you think
because
he just took over the world when
everyone found him
look you know being on the set with this
baby
we've all as cast members werner and
myself
and pedro have all said some different
things about
this very very irresistible
yoda i knew the first time i saw him
he's gonna be the star of the show
i was like i just reminded myself do
your part
play nicely in the sandbox because it's
the cutest baby ever
i got to be honest with you and
rightfully so and i know that they went
through great pains to figure out what
that baby would be physically how it
would be what it would be
and um and they they touched they
touched it
down they touched down in the right
place um so to be
tied to this baby is great just don't
let me catch you in season two
i know you better you better not hurt
him
but but you never know i just want to
spend all my time with him so as close
as i can get i will get
and believe me i'm good at getting close
well you are one of the busiest actors
you do so many roles that people just
adore
and cling to um is you kind of
checked off a lot of like the nerdy
bucket list like do you have a dream
role i know
a lot of times like you pop up in these
marvel rumor conversations
do you have a dream role that you want
to tackle next well there's been all
these rumors about being with marvel i
want to work with those guys i put it
out there all the time
i haven't created any you know i haven't
created any of those rumors but i
i worked years ago with louis d esposito
who's one of the one of the guys at
marvel back when he was doing cotton
club and i was doing cocktails the first
a.d
what they do is fantastic i want to do
something enduring with them
um and i i i know that
that for me historical dramas are really
great there's so many different
characters who
were um mixed race pushkin i'd love to
play
i think the marvel world would be likely
the next step for me
and then i would step back into playing
some characters i think that really did
change the world through their actions
and that it really didn't matter what
color they were that they were
mixed breeds or past in our world that
would address some of the
concerns about us championing
championing one movement uh or one
people without championing another
you know to understand that we're all
human again is i think we're about to
get to
and thankfully i'd like to be able to to
really play characters who start to
extend that in our world
and honor that so many i mean like
tucson love a tour
wouldn't play him he's a little darker
than i but a freedom fighter
there's so many people who were about
all people
and so yeah there's this i have my wish
list still
and i'll still look out look to do that
but i'm i'm really honored to be a part
of this
far cry 6 because i feel like these
games are becoming iconic
in many ways and allow us to think
differently and i'm so very honored to
be a part of
mandalorian it was like i had to really
pinch myself
uh and also because of the respect and
the with which with the way these people
work
they ask you to collaborate and so
you're really not looking at
you know your ego anymore you're looking
at what forwards and propels the story
in a direction that we can all relate to
and disney plus is a platform that
allows
a family to come together again and
watch this heroic
movement in entertainment um
together and so that sort of changes the
game because it focuses your attention
on
your ideals your morals making the right
decision
simpler to deal with than than having
it be um driven by sex drugs and rock
and roll it's deeper than that
really simpler than that but deeper than
that where do we belong
where should we be what's the next step
for all of us
as a humanity
well that is a fantastic note to end on
it was so great talking to you
um and i have to mention real quick that
i love that harley quinn show and it
better come back for another season
because it's so good
so good too you're all over it man yeah
i'm so happy
you asked great questions
you